nestled in the hills 45 miles north of
los angeles is the idyllic town of
newbury park this is where only a year
ago a single mom named laura was hoping
to fulfill her dream by opening a
restaurant called mamaritas
my grandmother was always cooking and i
was always being you know brought in to
help her cook and i loved it when she
passed away i said i'm going to go for
it i'm going to open up a place and i'm
going to name it after my grandmother
welcome to mamaritas
when i started the business it was
purely a takeout
catering business we built a really
great reputation in a very short period
of time and before i knew it i had
customers that said you need a
restaurant and based on my reputation
and the fact that everybody wanted this
i went for it all right guys we're open
for business
now i'm just adding a dining room and
i'm serving 200 people i've served you
know a thousand people in a catering job
how could it be so hard colorado's
really tender yeah
i cook for my marritos for six years a
lot of cheese really
nice with me she's my right hand and my
savior i mean she's family to me me my
love for you
laura is not a good boss because there's
not a lot of rules enforced and no one
necessarily knowing what they're doing
the direction i get from laura is a
little hit-and-miss and i don't really
think laura knows how to run her
restaurant i need a cocktail now
laura as a restaurant owner is
inexperienced because she never had any
training in this business completely
advanced pranking neutered so was the
creatory business but that was easier it
was small this is huge
i know i know
when she opened this restaurant and the
first week
really really visit after two three
weeks no more
during the first month we were just
packed the public they want the best
experience the best service the best
food sorry about that comp them out and
send them a free dessert please and i
didn't deliver it
and i'm begging people please come back
and give me another chance and some say
no i'll never go back there again the
debt that i've accrued with this
business is astronomical i'm on the
foreclosure list so there's a chance i
could lose the house
if i didn't believe in this i wouldn't
put my heart my soul every single thing
i've got into this i believe it can be
saved if i can fix
what's wrong
[Music]
some of the best mexican restaurants in
the world i'm not actually from mexico
they're here in southern california now
this restaurant here has been open just
12 months sadly it's only months away
from closing it's gotta be something
seriously wrong it looks
beautiful
wow
how are you i'm good thank you a
pleasure to meet you my wife now this is
mama
i am maggie i'm the mother of the owner
i thought you were a mamarita no i know
i'm mama rita's daughter mamarita's
daughter where is mamarita my marita is
uh buried in the cemetery over the hill
oh
i'm sorry to him no problem so
mamarita's your mother yes and it's your
daughter that is
laura laura i will take you to laura
excellent thank you my daddy
this will be my daughter laura how are
you
good to see you
can i just say this place looks stunning
thank you my goodness me somebody spent
a lot of money here
and you run the place i run the place i
try this is very different for me
catering is was my specialty that's what
i did before i opened the restaurant ah
i did very well at catering top dish
what would you recommend the homemade
tamales although i love tomatoes well
good to see you good to see you time to
eat i'm starving
excellent
this is my table thank you
when his order comes in we'll let you
know and you need to be the one that
cooks his food okay i think chef frenzy
he said everything menus
[Music]
i'm amazing how are you guys
brad brad good to see you
how long have you been here from the
beginning from the beginning
i can't believe how plushy this place is
i know it's like don't judge a book by
its cover because you walk in here and
you see this gorgeous place but
mamaritas doesn't live up to its
expectations if you can navigate me
around there's stuff to stay away from
milotes
taquitos
empanadas
[Music]
yeah and why would i stay away from them
just because
i just think they're really dry hmm i
respect you honestly thank you i'll bet
that i might forgot it
holy crap that's really scary within
five minutes been in the restaurant and
then told what to stay away from from
the headwaiter
hi yeah yeah
hot sauce thank you
this is cheryl this is uh my manager and
you manage the kitchen and the front of
the house um front of the house
i do catering as well what's wrong with
the place lack of customers
so why have we got lacking in customers
we need more customers we need to figure
out how to get more people in here
okay thank you and you're the manager
yeah oh my god a manager didn't know
what's wrong with the restaurant scary
okay look forward to catching up not
with the manager thank you
jesus
the manager that doesn't know what's
wrong i don't know what answer he wanted
i mean what was wrong with that lack of
customers brilliant that's great inside
isn't it
right here we go
let's start off with tamale
the chimichanga yeah let's go for a
burrito i think that's enough for now
all righty thank you
did anybody taste anything perla
everything was good yeah uh-huh if chef
ramsay doesn't like my grandmother's
recipes that concerns me anybody taste
the smallies
what he thinks
[Music]
i'm extremely hot
crunch
oh no god i hope the tamales are moist
jesus
it's like soaking wet newspaper
[Music]
that is so dry
my goodness me that's a fresh tamale
when we make them we make them in big
batches and then they're steamed and
then they're served because we make such
large volumes at a time
so are you sounding like the catering
company now yes and they go out like
that
it's they should be wet enough with the
sauce inside that when you resting them
they stay moist what an embarrassment
and this is your chef that ran a patient
business correct
cheese okay okay
[Music]
hates the tamales really perla
hates them
he said it's so dry it's inedible he
said it's embarrassing
yeah ready right
are you cooking everything yeah
curl it are you cooking the chimneys
uh-huh
i used a microwave for chimichangas for
one minute before they fry they taste
really really really good
okay chicken chimichangas
[Music]
chimichimi chimichanga
[Music]
it's dry
it's shards of dry chicken
i'm now wet
here's the thing
honestly
chimichangas chimichanga in the bin
what a shank
he hates the chimneys he didn't like him
i taste before it's really good the
flavor not to him apparently i'm
frustrated at my kitchen it's a bit of a
punch to the gut about my food
steak burrito
[Music]
at that
that's gross it has to be the biggest ad
for any diaper anywhere in california
oh no
oh
god my god
jesus
that's like eating wet cardboard have a
taste of that please
[Music]
bloody hell the steak was gamey it was
kind of like a car wash moist and mushy
oh my god
that is disgusting
let me taste the steak he says the steak
tastes like [ __ ] did you grill him fresh
steak for his burrito yeah you didn't
pull it from here right
didn't we taste everything before we put
it out
[Music]
it's really salty nobody tasted before
we did this
[Music]
damn it
when you have somebody come in that rips
apart all of your food
that that i was proud of it hurts a
little bit
i'm so sorry i'm not here to slag you
off however i just want something fresh
[Music]
after a lunch of disgusting dishes jeff
ramsey has quickly realized why this
beautiful restaurant is in an ugly
situation come round please thank you
so
this is
sadly the food was dry
it's like eating processed
is the food today the same that you
serve when you have a catering event
yeah
you'd be serving that crap why don't you
do it properly because everybody loved
my catering it's completely two
different monsters it's not gonna work
coming out of a catering business trying
to run a restaurant that costs how much
1.5
1.5
million dollars yes
oh my god and i'm 350 in the hole right
now on top of that so you're in for just
under two million dollars
god bless your grandmother but she must
be turning over in her grave
[Music]
after a miserable lunch that is
disgusting an alarming post-mortem
you're in for just under 2 million
chef ramsay decides he wants a better
understanding of how this team of people
work together in a dinner service
tonight i'm nervous that chef ramsay may
not think that the restaurant is running
efficiently i really hope that the staff
hold it together and that they shine
what can i get you
all right i'll put that in for you guys
thank you
i would say that the ticket time is not
even five minutes for entrees
[Music]
i cook really fast
[Music]
you're normally coming out this fast oh
yeah yeah all right
here we go rose gone
chilly
chicken taco i'm not dealing with my
suits
it's bringing the drive through isn't it
pretty much
with food flying out of the kitchen at
an incredible pace three minutes the
kitchen staff now has time to socialize
have you cleared the board all the
tickets gone yes wow so just standing
here the next couple of minutes i can't
believe how fast the food comes out it's
like a conveyor belt is that bad
it depends on quality okay while the
customers may appreciate the fast
service
they are not appreciating the food
[Music]
i mean it's not like i want to come back
no i know obviously stop stop stop the
only thing that's missing here
is a drive-through
i'm pissed he's telling me that all my
food is [ __ ] it's very frustrating when
i don't know how to do it another way
because this is all that i know
that is unbelievable this has to be the
fastest serving restaurant in america
tonight but it's not really a russian
it's a fast food factory what a joke
on the heels of a ridiculously fast
dinner service
ramsey suspects that shortcuts are being
taken in the kitchen wow
so it's time for a little investigation
[Music]
what are
those the tamales yeah
they're the frozen
ah
so these are your chimichangas are they
frozen as well yeah put awesome wow when
was all this made the month
oh my god
can you get me laura please
yes yes i'm here i'm here i'm here what
come around come round don't run not in
the kitchen here's the thing
you serve a chicken that was cooked
nearly two months ago you're frosting it
and then reheating it and you're
wondering why it's dry
were you aware of this or this is what
we did for catering
unbelievable that may be why the place
is struggling
where are the freezers freezer's there
oh my god
oh tortillas
i hope everything's right in there for
the shelving and all the food
[Music]
oh my
you're
god
aren't you look all this stuff here
i don't know
this is unbelievable look at that
this is what we did for catering you
must have hundreds of portions of stock
here
he just kept grabbing and grabbing and
stacking my arms with it all this
pre-cooked
pre-rolled frozen then defrosted it's
just absolutely appalling this is not a
restaurant
[Music]
i have a man back there ripping
everything apart telling me i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing when somebody
takes something that you have
and butchers it
it hurts
[Music]
a shocking discovery at dinner service
look at that you must have hundreds of
portions of stock confirms to chef
ramsay that problems at this restaurant
are bigger than he anticipated what day
lunch was disappointing
dinner
was shocking
it started off with the frost and serve
followed by defrost and serves followed
by
defrost and serve you're running a
factory
it's mass produced
treating food like a processing plant
perler is that quality what you cook
did you honestly think that serving
defrosted food
slopped out was going to make you a
success i did well at catering with it
you have driven away more customers than
you could ever imagine
chloe let's have a word with laura thank
you sit down
i um
i'm worried i don't get your level of
commitment to make this place work
[Music]
i i never pretended to know how to run a
restaurant
you're smart
but you're not being smart apparently
not
this food is sinking you faster than you
[ __ ] know it i don't want to lose
this
i want to figure out a way to fix it
make it great but you really have to
start taking responsibility
for what you're doing
the difference in running a catering
outlet to running a wonderful restaurant
is night and day and the quicker you get
that through your head will be the start
of the change
okay
i'm really sorry
too
[Music]
i've gone for something
that i
maybe shouldn't have gone for
and now i'm here
and i have to figure out a way to save
it
i'm scared
very scared
god
[Music]
thinking about what happened last night
laura
she's not stupid she's more scared
almost petrified so in order for me to
help her to get over that fear of change
i'm going to take the first step for her
there's only one way of doing this
goodbye frozen
look at that [ __ ]
oh my god what's the state of that a
year old
there's enough chimichangas here to last
me a lifetime
goodbye katie
hello restaurant
chef ramsay has found over 12 000 worth
of frozen food in the freezer good
morning how are you both fine thank you
now it's time to confront the owner and
the chef with his findings today's about
change yes
go and have a quick look around the
kitchen you'll see some adjustments
so far all looks the same
[Applause]
i was shocked everything was gone
my freezer was empty my walk-in
refrigerator was empty i had no idea
what was happening oh my god to show the
enormity of the amount of frozen food
gordon has not only removed it from the
freezer but has left it on display in
the restaurant
i was
completely floored
i had just the sinking feeling in my
stomach
look at this [ __ ]
[Music]
what's going on there
oh they've gone green
jesus look it's got his mexican sombrero
rice
chewy changes five dozen ten dozen
twelve dozen
ouch and
this
isn't
a catering business
i didn't know it was this bad last night
here's what concerns me more than
anything
these are from last year august
and july
last year
[Music]
what the [ __ ] going on
i'm shocked
i can see why
i have a good look i'm gonna wash my
hands
it [ __ ] stinks
i guess i should be on pearl or more to
make sure that the structure is there
and the things are being handled the way
that they should but then again i own
the restaurant so everything comes back
to be my responsibility
this has made me feel quite ignorant
[Music]
today's chef ramsay is hitting the
streets trying to gather former
customers of this young restaurant
he's hoping that they will hammer home
to laura what this community expects
from mamaritas
nice
[Music]
what is this
who are all these people chef ramsay
knows that often the best way to get his
point across is through the voices of
others ladies and gentlemen first of all
good afternoon i was pretty shocked to
see all these people showed up i really
didn't know what to expect thank you so
much for coming it means a lot for you
guys to make an effort to be here these
are ex-customers that we're here at the
beginning to support this restaurant
it's important that we understand what
went wrong when we had the chance to
open this restaurant please find out
what happened
i'd like to start okay
over the time we felt we weren't getting
the service that we wanted and the
creativity of the food was really
lacking
um on two different trips i got sick
within like a two-month period when i
came here two months later i got sick
again and i kind of stayed away
defrosting food the whole table kind of
got stomach issues afterwards
ouch
i guess i underestimated the palette of
the common person
some of the items we freeze and as we've
been going through we're thinking that
that's probably what it is and we're not
going to freeze anymore so hopefully
that will take care of that issue and
that's what we're changing thank you for
being so honest i can vouch for laura
frozen has gone
yes
i can't wait to see you again but next
time it's going to be inside the
restaurant rather than outside thank you
so much right we got work to do
that's an eye-opener today speaking to
all those people i realized people know
good food i respect that and that's what
i want to give them
[Music]
to make the transition from cooking
frozen to fresh chef ramsay has just the
challenge in mind to inspire laura and
her chef perla chicken shrimp i've got
steak here 30 minutes every bit of a
cook-off now choose between the shrimp
or the chicken and cook something really
delicious one minute gone let's go
it felt good working with fresh
ingredients it was fun to just
grab something and just throw it all
together and come up with something good
let me think let me think
what's matter i'm thinking
you're thinking
i'm really nervous because i don't have
idea for what i could 15 minutes left
[Music]
moving i was nervous about what she was
making no pressure burlap the creativity
seems not to be present five minutes
we're ready to play yeah
ready let's go
all right let's go
chef ramsay not only wants the staff to
taste the difference between frozen and
fresh not a single light on the plate
defrosted anywhere he's also looking for
the staff to choose which of the three
dishes goes on tonight's menu
okay what is it they are blackened
shrimp tacos that looks good telling
what is it garlic bread garlic breast
with garlic and salt
garlic and salt put on the chicken
breast
she just said garlic salt and that's it
it wasn't very creative and um
that scares me okay we've got a flat
iron steak briefly marinated mango salsa
served on a little bit of pickled
vegetables to finish with uh avocado
butter
okay let's go take a taste
[Music]
oh it's so good it was amazing to taste
chef ramsey's dish you could tell it was
going to taste good just by looking at
it
robert what do you think of the shrimp
how's the
[Music]
chicken pearl's dish had no flavor it's
a little bland i need something to spice
it up
okay good which dish goes on the menu
the mango salsa shrimp is really good so
both the shrimp
and the flour iron steak as special
tonight
i'm disappointed in perla given her
opportunity to try to shine
unfortunately i think it fell a bit
short
[Music]
for tonight's dinner service chef ramsay
has insisted on using only fresh
ingredients so for the first time
mamaritas led by laura and chef perla
will operate like a restaurant and not a
catering service hello
good to see you guys thank you you enjoy
now just letting you know our specials
are skirt steak with mango salsa and
black and shrimp tacos the steak special
okay we're cooking everything fresh now
so enjoy your meals
jeff you have anywhere special you want
me just doing my thing uh yeah that's
normal running against normal how's the
uh specials going specials are going
good you're gonna have some of those
steaks coming up now i've been pushing
it so it's coming i'm scared about
tonight cooking everything fresh like
this is it's going to be it's going to
be like something she's never done and
pearl has got to get into a whole new
mindset
perla's team has quickly produced the
first set of specials 24 yeah gracias
all right i got your chef's specials and
it appears as though the kitchen is
adapted well
but have they relay
you guys good was everything okay it's
rare
i'll take it back get into yours
[Music]
it's rare
guys
you gotta cook the steak
look it it is raw
look at that no this is a medium rare
this isn't medium rare anyway that is
rare
i want youth overseeing the entrees
making sure the steaks are cooked
properly and you shouldn't be doing this
little stuff you are the chef finally a
voice give me an apron
i have people that don't know what
they're doing so obviously i need to be
more hands-on in the kitchen specials
are going you guys leave those items out
so we can use them and get to them
easier i need these washed immediately
maria you're making me those churros
yeah wrap it up please
reef fire's gone out
my redo where's my did the other one go
out yet why'd you take why'd we take one
without the other
that's incredible on the back of all
this negativity i finally think the
penny's dropped with laura all of a
sudden she's found a voice and she's
treating this service like it's her last
did you get one of them yet one
there you go
for him i think
[Applause]
okay here's another steak up i need you
guys to keep up on this i shouldn't be
out back here doing this for you
right laura
let them do it now let them do it now
yeah laura has shown that she is willing
to step in to do whatever it takes to
help her restaurant but now chef ramsay
is looking for perla to do what she has
paid to do
run the kitchen i need you to step up
the mark now please
take control you want me to decorate the
place no no
look how many staff there are behind me
they were falling all over themselves in
the kitchen and there were a lot of them
on the line this is incredible laura
let's prepare to go to hell and back to
make sure this restaurant survives
however i don't get the same feeling
from a staff i don't think they actually
give a damn
unbelievable
[Music]
sake guys
[Music]
there's no excuse
i mean i it's like fish out of a [ __ ]
sushi bar
come on guys
if i don't do something immediately
it's gonna be gone tomorrow
i just hope we can do it
we gotta be able to do it
if we don't do it it's not gonna work
[Music]
tonight's difficult transition from
cooking frozen to fresh only confirmed
what chef ramsay was already feeling a
lack of confidence tonight didn't
exactly go to plan did it no it did not
perla is not a head chef i think tonight
confirmed that
surely you must see that
i i don't know what to do with that
pearl is family to me she's not an
employee that i can just cut you know
after so many years of being by my side
there was one strong asset quite
refreshing
that was you
i felt like this was your last service
you were almost fighting for your life
fighting to stay open fighting for every
customer every dollar and you care like
i've never seen you care before it was
the first time that i actually really
started to believe
that you've got what it takes to turn
this place around we're not going back
tomorrow we are relaunching this
restaurant
as a restaurant for the first time in
this town thank you come here thank you
so much for everything
[Music]
get some sleep okay it was great for
gordon to sit with me
and feel that somebody has some faith in
me i'm an absolute fighter and i tell
you this is the fight of my life
[Music]
gordon is looking to revive laura's
spirits and avoid a repeat of last
night's service so he's come up with a
surprise solution for the crippling
problem in the kitchen come in please
[Music]
now here's the big change
a humongous change hang on a second i've
got to get it
this
is norris
hi guys
this lady has been with me four years
she's an amazing chef obsessed
with mexican cuisine and i am giving her
to you as a gift
what she is going to do is install
a proper service in this restaurant
she's going to consult properly for the
first time since you've opened this
place i would just like to say that i'm
really really excited your restaurant is
beautiful thank you we're going to make
your kitchen beautiful we're going to
make your food beautiful thank you it's
going to be great thank you i'm excited
one hell of a talented chef and i mean
that
thanks thank you my daddy
oh god i can't believe it this is an
opportunity of a lifetime she's gonna
teach perla so much for the first time
in a long time
i have some hope and i uh i think we're
gonna get through this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gordon is hoping chef consultant maurice
will get the kitchen in order but
there's another huge change tonight the
menu first of all look at the colors
it's like a rainbow yeah
it's fresh seasonal and it is incredibly
authentic taco salad that looks good
slowly braised
the sizzling fajitas that is going to be
piping hot please be careful have a
taste
mmm oh my gosh you guys mmm the flavors
that shrimp is good the new menu is
awesome my mother would be so proud of
right now we're all so excited last
night
[Music]
with mama rita's facing its biggest
night ever chef ramsay is willing to
give perla one more chance to command
the kitchen but this time he has
installed the safety valve and her name
is maurice
right uh paula yes tonight we really
have to show that you can adapt
to cooking in a restaurant and there's a
big difference
maurice is here to help you but she
can't do everything so show some spirit
to try and get this place back up to
where it should have opened nine months
ago yeah
excellent good luck how can we not have
a successful night i mean i've got one
of gordon's chefs to work in the kitchen
and i think perrla will do all right
hello what's your name under gun okay
come with me
there you go this is our new menu
everything's fresher now we're kind of
revamping everything let's just start
off with that
guacamole to start stay heated
i will uh put that order in and it
should be up shortly
[Music]
so make sure you mark them okay start
marking appetizer dinner
parlor yeah i need you to set me up a
fish taco okay
carla are you ready for the tacos
listen to me please let's get 34 out
whatever that is i need that
set me up the plate so i can just put
the fish on there please please larry's
i need to pick up 34 yes yeah i have it
i just need the plate set up right there
is yeah sure there's four of them
standing watching you do everything no
one's doing anything else you've got to
pick it up
are you ready for the tacos no not ready
can you believe that
sure
so you just walk right past that table
everything's empty in there you can't
clear away what's going to do for you
this time
you guys all done here
it's 20 minutes into dinner service
pull your tickets don't let him hang
like that and already perla is
struggling to organize the kitchen and
her staff i've never seen so many people
standing still behind the line what are
we waiting on firing the orders or not
yes yeah fella i need to start firing
tickets now please um
what's unfolding in my eyes it's
fascinating i'm just trying to get it
set
like your normal restaurant not like a
canteen where they're serving a little
mass
perrla was still in a catering mindset
and with the cooking fresh and cooking
to order it's obvious she didn't know
how to do that and make it happen
perla is clearly being exposed for her
lack of leadership and the kitchen is
slowly sinking
we need to get organized this is not
this is not working but finally an hour
into dinner service appetizers are
leaving the kitchen
chips and not enough cheese okay all
right i'll go ahead and send this back
for you guys
let's go okay we gotta focus what's the
deal with 33. all right
burn chips snow beans and not enough
cheese [ __ ] sake guys
three five some more cheese on there but
no don't burn the chips yeah sorry this
is the difference between just taking
stuff out of a fridge and dipping it in
fryer they got fried this morning or
trying to cook it fresh
on top of the three people's mistake
they give me they give it to me raw send
it back what's wrong with that um
it's incredible you have the most
amazing looking restaurant and a great
tasting menu but if you haven't got the
right staff to put it off you're screwed
take your tickets talk to me what what
tables have gone out from the first
picket perrla was completely absent
marla yes please put numbers on him i'm
not running the table i don't know
what's going on i had to turn my head a
hundred times to say
perla what's next call it out what are
we doing herla talk to me you gotta talk
to us you can we're not we're not
psychic here perla realized the ticket
times and started feeling the pressure
she fell apart
take control she's not equipped to work
a line there's not one ounce of lime
material in that woman
it's relaunch night at mamarita's perla
has shut down and the kitchen is at a
standstill laura yes
[Music]
i couldn't have made it any easier for
her it's clear now she's not making the
transition from a line [ __ ] process
frozen defrosted crap to cooking fresh
that is not head chef material we're not
looking for a super duper fine dining
chef i'm just looking for a cook that
can cook from [ __ ] start to finish
tonight's been obvious yes but can i
will make a comment i have i have a
woman that has has stuck with me through
thick and thin for six years okay my big
question to you yes are you her boss or
are you her friend i am her boss joe
you're your friend
it would break my heart to not have
perla as my head chef
but right now i have to stand back and
really look at what's best for my
business who else brother
okay look at me maurice take over the
line yes you outside five minutes get
some food take her outside let's go
unbelievable
it's okay
it's okay
look at me it's okay i'm scared too
i'm scared and it's hard okay
i'm frightened all hell right now i've
got to try to pull this off with the
staff that i've got and this new way of
cooking okay that'll be okay
i promise you it'll be okay
[Music]
coming in 30 seconds with perla off the
line and the reese in control get some
lime on here please and finish these for
me mama rita's kitchen is finally on
track
mommy tacos up piping hot hear the fish
tacos can i have a ramekin please
technically i wasn't supposed to be
online i was just supposed to supervise
but i can't watch them go down good job
now keep it up let's finish tonight
[Applause]
all right carnitas you got the mahi
you can do it just focus chef ramsay's
plan and theresa's rescue of the kitchen
has resulted in customers being
satisfied this is one you want to keep
you like the new rihanno yeah and the
relaunch ends on a positive note without
no race we wouldn't have been able to
get through tonight thank you so much
for coming in thank you you guys clean
up a little she knows her stuff i mean
she's clearly a great chef
[Music]
while the relaunch was a success
unfortunately no one is in the mood for
celebrating certainly not perla
and definitely not chef ramsay
tonight was made more difficult than it
ever had to be pela's not a leader she's
never going to step up to the mark of a
head chef ever it's not rocket science i
know no over the next two weeks i want
you to separate the brigade focus on the
strengths the weaknesses okay thank you
thank you so much
wonderful pearl of strength isn't being
a chef and this whole scenario has
brought that to light and now it's
blaringly clear that i need to do
something about it laura the future
success of this ration is in your hands
you don't extract out of her everything
she knows about cooking you're mad it
will never ever work if you step
backwards to your old ways i won't do
that again well i'm gonna run it like a
restaurant
next time you come you're gonna see some
staff changes promise me i i i give you
my word come here stand strong and good
luck
[Music]
i've got one hell of a headache
did we honestly take a caterer and turn
her into a restauranteur that question
will only be answered when she finally
decides on what to do with perler and
her kitchen team
what a nightmare
holy chimi changes
[Music]
after gordon left laura worked with
maurice to organize the kitchen and the
staff into a fully functioning
restaurant once the system is
implemented i think that will make it
much much smoother that makes sense
and after two weeks laura finally made
the staff change she promised chef
ramsay she installed a new head chef
moving perla out of the kitchen and back
to catering
moving forward now there is definitely
going to be a split between my catering
and the restaurant they are going to be
two different businesses well guys
thanks for coming in
i don't think my eyes were open and they
haven't been open for a very long time
and it took gordon to come in here and
to get me to open them
you